Oi boa tarde obrigado
obrigadíssimo vamos embora vamos embora
com o cão está com fome e
[Música]
quem é que vai comer um é Vimeo hoje
quem é É o surto do Suzuki
Deus é um facão à vontade Não não é para
com essa caixa nada não eu estava dentro
acha que ele vai estar ele vai adorar
lá fora
não quero fazer alguns não vou conseguir
é isso
pessoal sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e hoje pessoal eu vou mostrar a
primeira experiência do meu cão a comer
um F1000 reparem só tá aqui
preparadíssimo para ele já fui buscar
logo que ele está super ansioso porque
ele sabe que é para ele ok ele agora
está a fazer das suas a tentar destruir
o Pikachu só para me chamar a atenção
mas reparem só quando ele mostro explico
México é isto é
é porque não é para quem é tu é
e
não não não sabe não é não não é não é
hoje eu tô aqui vai experimentar pela
primeira vez um e-mail ok e como vocês
devem calcular não é nada bom dar Este é
o nosso cão Porque tem um monte de
conservantes tem muitas coisas que fazem
mal ao estômago obviamente Então hoje eu
vou preparar um F1000 a medida do zouk
Ok tudo com produtos biológicos como
produtos saudáveis que os cães podem
comer mas ele vai achar que o amor de
Deus saiu diretamente do McDonald's e
quem vai acabar por comer esta F1000
obviamente não percebeu porque estamos
em dieta não é sabem que estão no
processo de perca de peso então esta
F1000 obviamente que vai para nossa
amiga Ana a nesta aqui a surpresa
quem está aqui é todo teu
é tudo teu não calma que principais
comer isso mesmo calma OK então Qual é o
plano eu vou construir todo um
hambúrguer só zouk Ok e tu vais comer as
coisas dele ele não pode saber que tu é
que estás a comer um hambúrguer real ok
ok porque senão o cachorro fica triste
porque eu quero muito essa agulhas sabes
como é que são os cães não é e principal
anos o que olha olha para que o meu tá
tudo entusiasmado meu Deus ele não larga
a minha perna agora que a mas o que já
vamos comer porque ele tá furioso que eu
quero muito amor calma o brinquedo é
para os o que eu quero não espera da
polícia
e se sair os recado incrível sair eu
quero se for os que eu vou passar a
batata
hambúrguer
e agora vamos ver com
as almofadas e
[Música]
e
não não
é uma máquina enganada eu achei que é
ser um peluche olha para isto é não mas
eu cheguei aqui na minha altura se um
bonecos muito mais importante peluches e
brinquedos mesmo de facto agora site
dentro da pele um podre É isso aí depois
tu não estás aqui olha deve as orelhas
é isso
[Música]
vamos lá então esconder aqui o F1000 Já
sabes Podes comer depois ele não pode
ver a comer e entretanto pessoal já
deixe muito like aqui neste vídeo Bora
lá então preparar um hambúrguer um F1000
a medida do zouk coisas que ele possa
comer eu vou tentar montar um hambúrguer
todo orgânico com coisas que eu sei que
ele pode comer e que não fazem mal ao
estômago
ingredientes senhora não faz mal até um
cenário bastante saudável para os cães
vou tentar fazer as batatas fritas com
cenoura ali na Air Fryer vai ficar
estaladiço ou vai adorar o pepino vai
sempre substituir aquele [ __ ] o que tem
dentro de humor eles sabem a salada vai
ser feita com espinafre eu comprei eu
também e o pão de hambúrguer
em uma delas bem grossa
Eu também estou bem que a batata doce um
pouco tóxica para o estômago dos cães
Mas se for cozinhada não há problema
nenhum vocês podem dar algumas animal de
estimação Vamos cozinhar lá então também
na Air Fryer e vamos substituir pelo pão
essa mistura de queijos decisão para dar
um saborzinho Oeste A única diferença do
queijo é que nesse mesmo muito pouquinho
porque contém muita gordura eles podem
engordar facilmente então não convém
abusar tudo isso vai dar um hambúrguer
super biológico e saudável para os o que
comer OK nós não queremos ter o passo
mal do estômago mexe vamos colocar tudo
dentro da caixa e vamos ver a reação
dele ele vai achar que está a comer um
Big Mac está tudo bem o que importa é
que esteja feliz em não temos que isso
eu acho que ele quer relacionado
Eu quero uma bolacha que que era uma
borrachinha e também
a
pizza eu já percebi que isso é olha diz
aqui ainda instruções é para tu tirar as
bolas para dentro da boca dos Reis isso
faz uma bola e tu tiras para aqui ó o
jogo jogo aí eu acho que vou mostrar
isso o pessoal eles merecem verdes Ontem
nós passamos por umas férias pessoal aí
que vamos perder muitos artigos lá à
venda e nós achamos aqui este palhaço
não é olha só eu acho isso um pouco
macabro porque eu não tenho Alemanha e
bonito mas que assustador não sei se é
por ser um palhaço mas ele vez em quando
toca música O que é muito estranho ó ó
o seu cheiro aqui pelo MEC toca
[Música]
os trouxas esta assustador fofo
não não não que esta noite de coco é
muito estranho
Ah
não fica assim meio inclinado
é mas quando está acompanhado pelos está
muito assustador Não não
quero que os que eu vou fazer um
hambúrguer não
preciso de ajuda no final Então pessoal
o primeiro passo construir um pão do
nosso hambúrguer e vamos fazer ele com
batata doce ser temos que lavar bem a
batata
vai que tem aqui alguma coisa que faz
mal ao Juke e Isso não pode acontecer
esclera e diz
quem apanhou apanhou vamos cortar assim
por aqui ó essa parte aqui já vai dar
uma rodela de pão esta vai ser a fatia
do pão de baixo
eu quero que fique do mesmo tamanho
agora foi esta fatia de pão ainda ficou
melhor
isso é que está mas estão Igualmente não
vai saber ao mesmo o Dark isso não tem
graça assim mas não falaram que não pode
comer o que nós comemos agora para
substituir alface do e-mail ou do Big
Mac o que quer que seja vamos usar então
o espinafre vamos lá deixar aqui alguns
Ok para substituir ou picão vamos usar
as pino este movimento que não está
mergulhado em vinagre que não tem açúcar
Extra é corretamente biológico
e toma lá
E ai que o céu
é bom festas
e não é eu gosto de tu pedir meu só que
não tem a pessoa que vocês acham que ele
vai gostar do hambúrguer ou não comenta
aí já vamos usar quatro um pouquinho da
cenoura que já está ralada também só
para dar aquele toquezinho juntamente
com o queijo assim esquema do hambúrguer
atenção eu não preciso escrever o mais
importante que vou tirar agora do
frigorífico tenho aqui uma carta
indicada já lavei as mãos Ok vamos
tentar fazer aqui um hambúrguer que
quando passei lá no pede pessoal eu pedi
uma carne de vaca de primeiro o que é
portanto uma vai comer uma carne
qualquer uma carne muito boa e sem muita
gordura porque isso podem fazer mal em
excesso de gordura então fica apenas com
a carne é o que ele gosta vou mostrar um
pouco a carne atenção sempre sem sal tá
OK Fica assim ao natural o mais natural
possível e ele vai fazer melhor Ok se
você quiser alguma coisa deste ano para
você animal de estimação tenho sempre
atenção no que ele pode comer no que não
pode comer investir em vão a internet
obviamente que não vão encher um
hambúrguer cheio de chocolate a uma foto
que o chocolate ok Nem luvas nem abacate
tem muita coisa que é tóxica para eles
então também sempre atenção se forem dar
comida ao seu animal de estimação agora
vamos usar um copo para fazer uma forma
certinho aqui do hambúrguer assim OK meu
Deus isto está perfeito
a festa carne vamos usar depois para é
só este é um hambúrguer do Hulk Olha
isso já
está agora vamos lá me delas Ok eu acho
que ele vai amar este hambúrguer Vamos
então cozinhar a carne e a batata doce e
para isso eu vou usar essa ele porque é
mais rápido também e a não ser para ela
também ajuda muito a retirar a gordura
esta que possa ter a carne ou o que for
mesmo por causa da Carne como têm pouca
gordura mas tem a gordura Está aqui vai
escorrer tudo em baixo então vai ficar
um hambúrguer mais toda Ainda Calma não
é para começar agora só que não é agora
agora o nosso pão aqui está ele
não sei vocês temperaturas mas eu vou
tentar usar normalmente como eu faço a
carga né que é 190
posso deixar por uns catorze minutos
talvez
e bora
[Música]
Ana acabou de se trancar ali na casa de
banho e eu acho que sei o que ela está a
fazer porque os o que está na porta com
uma cara de desconfiado bem o que é que
se passa Sasuke
que é que se passa o que é que a mamãe
está a fazer
É eu sei que tu estás a fazer
a
música e também nós sabemos o que estás
a fazer o quê que tu estás a fazer nada
só podia tu vem para casa vem comer um
assim não não sei que fala na casa de
banho
elas o que vem
dentro não
comenta embaixo de Vocês já comeram
alguma vez dentro da casa de banho Como
assim sem nojento olha o cheiro que tá
aí dentro até tem um aviso aqui na porta
aqui na porta usar proteção respiratória
não é mas não é verdade está bonitinha
pior partes aí o que é um
porcaria que a tua mãe está a comer e
outro é outra coisa até disfarça na
cozinha e também vai estar um pouco
eu quero uma trinca e vocês acompanhar o
meu último vídeo sabem que eu estou em
dieta Ok então tá sendo muito difícil
para mim não comer porcarias o que comer
McDonald's uma vez por semana OK mas eu
não tenho que não comi nada assim com
muitas calorias e tudo mais mas enfim é
o sacrifício para perder peso esse aqui
isso no futuro não vai dar mais
vantagens então eu vou me sentir melhor
e tudo mais Então é só resistir
com o que bom aspeto que ótimas para
olha só essa hambúrguer era mesmo que
bom aspecto Olha isso
e eu acho que ele vai estar bem mais
este
é que está a nossa
batata cozinhada está boa por dentro
está mesmo no.
Ah tá
ir para em como a senhora fica
estaladiça
olha isso tá incrível estão agora eu
preciso que me tragas aquele mesmo todo
porque eu tenho que fazer embalagem toda
começou a caminho Ok eu preciso de
embalagens que eles porque eu vou
colocar as batatas dentro do sistema
bens batata fez até quem é
e não era o pão
OK agora vamos colocar
a carne e a salada a salada já está
lavada ok pessoal aqui assim mais uma
cenoura
assim
só faltava aqui um molho tipo uma
maionese não quer dizer assim eu não vou
arriscar porque eu tenho certeza que eu
não pode comer isso então vai ser molho
mesmo e agora a próxima fatia de pão e
está vontade pessoal o nosso Big Mac
para cachorro Olha isso que coisa linda
meu atentado à vontade de comer assim
juro
bom aspecto meu
[Aplausos]
vamos embalar
e
enquanto eu estou a fazer isto o
hambúrguer também é repete por que não
convém dar um hambúrguer de quente Ok
faz mal azuki então Como arrefecer
encontrou uma garrafa PET vamos sair
para cortar as batatinhas fritas uma
aqui
E aí estão elas Olha que tu vens comer
Olha que tu vai escrever o
que não pode deixar de faltar pessoal
brinquedo para o em mim ir lá pois é
calma estamos que surpresa Tá difícil já
está sagradas mais o brinquedo aqui está
aqui está pessoal nós FM para uso qsuper
adaptado com produtos biológicos que não
faz mal estamos gravar a reação dele a
Comer este hambúrguer e vou levar para a
sala e vamos ver como é que ele vai ter
visto eu já sei que vais trabalhar mas
agora não achei nenhum ok E aí vamos ver
o que ele vai fazer olha vai sujar a
sala toda
tô com vontade no primeiro não esquece
brinquedo
não gostou dá um brinquedo eu acho que
diz aqui
[Música]
mas tem mais ali dentro Eu tenho que dar
esta refeição azul que isso não já sei
que vai sujar a sala toda agora vamos
ver se Não gostas das Batatinhas
primeiro calma aí
E ai que bom
acho que tá aprovado né Acho que sim
mano
E aí
E ai que bom
a senhora rústicas
obviamente falta a sala aqui né mas é
Olá tudo bem primeiro filho meu quando
provar a carne chega a batata e isto
este aqui será um desses largar a
E olha que amor é este que bom
E aí
e
olha lá ganhou o carro ou não não caiu
no sofá não não comer aqui no sofá foi
uma ideia agora é só
o OK vou dar aos bocadinhos é melhor Ok
vamos ver se ele gosta da carne ai que
bom é muito
[Risadas]
fofinho eu senti que isso foi um
obrigado
mais um bocadinho
Ai que bom
agora dá uma 30 grande faz como o papato
ensinou uma 30 grande então tá que está
OK agora vai a batata doce a carne e um
bocadinho da salada Olha só como que
está derretido que bom
o Ok fica tá um pouquinho quente mas não
é preocupante fiquem vou
a portaria
o Tom aa um OK eu estou do pão também
e agora eu vou abandonar isso aqui no
chão ele vai comer à vontade
E aí
E ai que bom eu vou apagar embora
faz o que eu deixei ele é um prato
especialmente para tu comer um
hambúrguer Não e tu leva disse para
tapete
meu Deus
hambúrguer do que ele é como nós ele
deixou no fim né e ainda vai comer ainda
vai comer ainda comeu É isso mesmo mas o
que não se desperdiça nada muito bem Eu
adorei o pessoal eu acho que sim eu só
todo contente estava voz aqui eu quero
mais está à procura de mais a agora é
hora do descanso missão cumprida pessoal
uso que é morou F1000 já sei que ele tem
que fazer mais vezes porque ele continua
ali Acho espera que ele traga outro
hambúrguer meu outras forma errada nem
sei porque eu tenho ali comida à
disposição mas eu adoro hambúrguer e já
sabem também só não acompanha o meu
canal de jogos O que está a passar aqui
atrás é precisamente o meu canal Dark
frame 2.0 podem seguir o link que está
embaixo se não também o canal da Ana da
Kira lá no teu canal agora estou indo
ativa mas eu vou voltar e tá ali no
canto uma surpresa que não está a ser
filmada e esperou do completamente
diferentes mas eu acho que vocês vão
adorar vai fazer alguma coisa com este
palhaço
Olha
é o palhaço e
eu tenho uma caixa de música dentro né
mas não sim olha aqui atrás da para dar
corda tem uma cor Deus não tinha visto
que faz sentir agora
Tá mas porquê que não toca mais eu não
eu só tava quando quer não gosto
de pessoas que tenham gostado aqui neste
vídeo já está ver se quiser ver mais
vídeos E
aí pessoal fica bem até a próxima
E aí
é cercada de que está à espera no médico
o
meu Deus está ficar mais alta tá com b